nous sommes submergés par l'accélération
de l'épidémie la seconde vague sera sans
doute plus meurtrière que la première
vient d'avertir emmanuel macron dans son
allocution en français pour y faire face
le président annonce donc un re
confinement à l'échelle nationale à
partir de vendredi mais plus souple que
le premier vécu en mars et en avril
dernier
alors si les commerçants les bars et les
restaurants seront fermées est les
crèches écoles collèges et lycées
resteront eux ouverts télétravail
généralisée et les visites en maison de
retraite
autorisé en décrit tout de suite toutes
ces annonces on décrypte cette prise de
parole du président de la république
avec nos invités et avec nous ce soir
alexis poulain éditorialistes bonsoir à
vos côtés arnaud stéphan communicants ex
conseiller communication presse de
marion maréchal-le pen messieurs bonsoir
alors arnaud stéphan ce soir
qu'est ce que vous avez entendu on
annonce un confinement où un couvre-feu
élargi finalement annoncé tain c'est un
retour évidemment un confinement mais la
première chose qui me marque
c'est ce sont les termes du président de
la république
il a d'abord commencé par nous expliquer
les raisons pour lesquelles tout était
fichu et que nous n'avions pas d'autre
solution que celle d'un confinement dur
parce que c'est un confinement dur qui
nous est proposé est pas du tout quelque
chose de beaucoup plus soft comme il
avait été annoncé il ya certaines
phrases qui ont été sortis quelques
quelques heures avant cette allocution
gardé de dire les français vont
connaître
métro boulot dodo et bien c'est
exactement ça nous sommes nous sommes
confinés par le président de la
république nous sommes nous sommes de
nouveau retour à la maison avec les
documents sauf que maintenant en plus on
nous demande absolument d'être productif
en plus c'est à dire que nous n'aurons
rien d'autre à faire que d'être d'aidé
objet de production voilà ça c'est en
tout cas ce qui ressort des propos du
président de la république enfin c'est
ce qui marque en premier plan alexis
poule à donc ce soir effectivement les
écoles restent ouverts dans le même
temps bars et restaurants les commerces
resteront fermés toutes les mesures qui
ont été annoncées ce soir est ce que
vous les trouvez cohérente pour lutter
contre la seconde vague de l'épidémie
non mais la cohérence ça fait longtemps
qu'elle a déserté l'elysée et les
mesures prises depuis mars
aujourd'hui on a un président sans tête
un qui court qui essaye de mettre un
peuple en cage
on est des hamsters dans une boule on
tourne en rond c'est à dire qu'on fait
exactement comme s'il n'y avait pas eu
une première vague comme si on n'avait
rien appris malgré ce qui fait croire en
disant que nous avons appris non pas du
tout regardé on a fermé des lits on a
continué de fermer des lits de
réanimation on va péniblement augmenté
pour revenir à dix mille lits alors
qu'on était plus lors de la première
vague
on est en train de re confiné de
refermer des commerces qui ont eu du mal
à redémarrer l'activité
cette fois ci pour eux c'est fini je
crois que le ras-le-bol est complet pour
les commerçants et qui ne comprennent
surtout pas la cohérence justement de
ces mesures parce qu'il n'y en a pas une
étude est sorti aujourd'hui une étude
israélienne qui a dit que les écoles
étaient effectivement des bombes à
retardement pour la propagation de ce
virus et les enfants étaient extrêmement
porteur du virus
eh bien regardez la rentrée comme elle
est et regagne organisé en france elle
n'a pas été organisée elle a été fait
comme s'il n'y avait pas de covin et
c'est ça qui fait qu'on en est là
aujourd'hui
donc je ne vois pas comment ce
gouvernement peut continuer de se
regarder dans la glace que ce soit jean
michel blanquer que ce soit monsieur
castex qui était responsable dudit
confinement et que ce soit ce président
qui nous ment devant la caméra qui a
menti
c'était le cas le 14 juillet en disant
que la france serait prête en cas de
deuxième bague et ce soir il a eu le
culot de dire que personne n'a vu venir
c'est deuxième banque personne n'a vu
venir l'explosion des cas c'est faux il
n'avait qu'à écouter des médecins le
conseil scientifique tout le monde à peu
près a expliqué que la rentrée ne devait
pas être fait comme ça les professeurs
dans les écoles qui étaient eux très
conscient que le coc vide et est en
train d'exploser puisqu'il soit ils ont
été malades eux mêmes soit il avait plus
de trois ou quatre cas dans les classes
n'a encore une fois pas de vagues
il ne fallait pas en parler les
soignants qui ont alerté qui on demande
est toujours plus de moyens qui ont dit
mais qu'est ce que vous faites
finalement c'est ça n'a aucun sens donc
ce monsieur emmanuel macron président de
la république française qui a passé deux
belles vacances rien préparé le voilà
aujourd'hui nous demandant de faire
encore des efforts parce qu'il a été
incapable de nous protéger parce qu'il a
été incapable de mettre en place les
mesures qui ferait qu aujourd'hui nous
ne serions pas dans un deuxième
confinement et ce confinement est bien
pour essayer de sauver l'économie mais
ça ne suffira pas malheureusement je le
crains pour de nombreux entrepreneurs
c'est la clé sous la porte
à partir de ce soir de vendredi soir eh
bien il faudra continuer d'aller
travailler on va garder les écoles
ouvertes alors que c'est même là que le
virus se transmet et se propage
donc ça n'a encore une fois aucun sens à
part nous prendre pour des hamsters mais
je le redis encore une fois on ne met
pas un peuple en cage et regarder autour
de nous en espagne en italie un peu
partout ailleurs je crois que partout
les populations en ont ras-le-bol de ces
mesures
idiote qu'ils ne comprennent pas parce
que le virus continue et parce que la
réponse qu'il fallait avoir c'était
éviter le contact la rentrée comme elle
a été organisée
testez isolé faire en sorte que les
chaînes de reproduction du virus soit
cassé très tôt tout ça n'a pas été fait
et qu'est ce qu'il reste pour nos
gouvernants le confinement c'est à dire
empêcher les gens empêcher et finir
mettre en terre la liberté ce
gouvernement est morbide les cimetières
vous restait ouvert mais les parcs vont
encore fermée voilà à peu près la vie
que nous propose
emmanuel macron c'est une vie de mort
alors on va peut s'arrêter un sur
l'école à vous parliez de cette étude
israélienne il y en a une autre à une
étude de l'université d'edimbourg elle
dit que le confinement total avec
fermeture des écoles réduire est de 52 %
le taux de reproduction du virus arnaud
stéphan est ce que ce soir pour faire
face à cette seconde vague il aurait
fallu taper plus fort finalement vous
savez le général macarthur expliqué
qu'il y avait deux mots qui expliquait
les défaites
trop tard voilà ce poulain viens de le
dire tout à l'heure la rentrée déjà été
fait il ya une circulation extrême
oui il y à une circulation avec les
enfants oui les
enfants sont susceptibles de pouvoir
contaminé évidemment les parents vous
avez vous avez ce qui s'est passé dans
les universités avec le maintien de
manière complètement absurde des
week-ends d'intégration où on a vu que
ça a été ça a été une
ça a été une source de contamination
très importante
qu'est ce que vous allez expliquer
aujourd'hui vous allez expliquer à des
enfants qui déjà ont des vraies
difficultés à pouvoir se concentrer avec
des professeurs qui porte le masque
vous savez qu'aujourd'hui il ya déjà des
il ya une baisse considérable de
l'apprentissage chez les enfants parce
qu ils sont bloqués de plus en plus avec
des adultes qui ne leur renvoie comme
visage que celui du masque c'est un
c'est un vrai souci il y a des vrais
problèmes psychologiques qui sont en
train d'être créées par chez les enfants
moi je veux bien que demain on nous
explique il aurait fallu peut-être aussi
fermé les écoles peut-être qu'il aurait
fallu aussi fermé les collèges les
lycées
mais de quelle société est en train de
parler
finalement on est en train de parler
d'une société où on va demander aux
parents d'aller travailler parce qu'il
ya des métiers pour ne peut pas
substituée par le télétravail c'est faux
de dire que ça serait tellement facile
d'aller d'aller uniquement travail
télétravail et que toute la famille
serait finalement dans une bulle et
serait complètement hors du temps non
c'est faux il ya des gens qui sont
obligés d'aller travailler parce que ce
sont des gens qui sont dans des métiers
de production et qui va s'occuper des
enfants à ce moment là qui va s'occuper
des enfants
on va on va créer des milliers et des
milliers de postes de nounous on va d
scolariser des enfants parce que parce
que tout d'un coup on s'est aperçu que
on avait raté encore une fois qu'on
s'est dit on s'était pris trop tard pour
préparer une rentrée correctement non
c'est un c'est un vrai sujet et les
conséquences seront dramatiques pas
seulement des conséquences économiques
celle-là nous savons déjà nous allons
être impactés de manière très importante
il y aura aussi des un impact
psychologique et particulièrement chez
les enfants particulièrement chez les
plus jeunes
cet épisode de confinement le premier
nous n'en avons pas encore totalement
tiré les leçons
je suis très inquiet de ce deuxième
volet particulièrement chez les plus
jeunes alors emmanuel macron qui appelle
à ne pas céder au poison de la division
ça va être compliqué selon voies alexis
poulain mais le rêve des manuels macron
c'est le parti unique est une dictature
sanitaires c'est pas le rêve des
français je crois qu'il a oublié qu'on
vivait dans une démocratie en république
et que ce peuple français qu'il a du mal
à aimer eh bien oui c'est des gaulois
réfractaires c'est dégueulasse et des
gens qui sont rarement content et il ya
de quoi ne pas être content quand on
voit la gestion de cette crise depuis
mars par ce gouvernement d'incapables
parce que oui il fallait prévoir et
gouverner c'est prévoir et donc il
fallait pérenniser délit il fallait
écouter les soignants il fallait
organiser la rentrée en divisant les
classes ou bien en en faisant un
protocole sanitaire qui évitait ces
bombes à coville qui ont été les salles
de classe il fallait encore une fois
poussé le télétravail davantage dès que
c'était possible
et puis encore une fois on ne seront
neuf à pas lutter contre ce virus avec
une politique de mort les gens ont
besoin d'optimisme ils ont besoin de
vivre ils ont besoin de se retrouver
ils ont besoin des bars ils ont besoin
des restaurants ils ont besoin du cinéma
ils ont besoin du théâtre ils ont besoin
la création ils ont besoin en fait de se
changer les idées
et là que propose des modèles macron
métro boulot dodo et pour les plus
riches encore une fois le séparatisme
aujourd'hui vous aviez des bouchons dans
toute l'île de france parce que ceux qui
ont les moyens les parisiens qui ont les
moyens sont vite partis à la campagne
sachant ce qui arrivait et pour les
autres eh bien ce sera la punition comme
en mars vous allez rester confinés et en
plus vous n'aurez même pas le droit de
vous balader le week end pour prendre un
peu l'air mais on marche sur la tête
enfin les gens qui ne sont pas malades
vont devenir malade mais pas du virus
d'une folie qui s'empare d'un pays parce
que on oblige les gens à s'arrêter de
vivre pour ce virus qui certes tu
certains mais encore une fois le taux de
mortalité
on n'est pas face à imola on est sur un
virus dangereux wiki qui touche les plus
fragiles souvent les plus âgés le
président l'a rappelé et là que fait mme
nelles macron il fait payer à tout un
peuple
l'incurie des gouvernants pas que le
sien qui fait que notre système
sanitaire est maintenant sur les rotules
et qu'on a attaqué l'os et que comme la
crise est là et bien on ne peut pas
faire face à la crise or il a menti
le 14 juillet or jean castex a menti à
l'université d'été du medef
tout cela en disant que la france était
prête qu on avait tout ce qu'il fallait
que non art confinement était impossible
et bien voilà c'est possible et il
faudrait encore les écouter et les
croire je crois que cette fois ci c'est
la goutte d'eau
je ne vois pas comment on va pouvoir
s'en sortir économiquement après ce
deuxième confinement quoi qu'il en coûte
10 est il là il vient de proposer à la
france une banqueroute
arnaud stéphan avec ce retour en arrière
est ce que vous craignez un problème
d'acceptabilité chez les français
notamment chez les petits commerçants ou
alors chez les français qui est
effectivement se seront dans leur petit
appartement qui ne pourront pas sortir
ce qu'il va y avoir cette fois un réel
problème d'acceptabilité selon vous
alors l'acceptabilité c'est un peu
compliqué peut-être comme aux jeux il ya
un mot très simple vous savez dans le
dans l'histoire particulièrement en
france c'est le consentement à chaque
fois qu'il ya eu des grandes crises en
france c'est parce qu'il y avait une
difficulté au consentement
souvent ça a été le consentement à
l'impôt ça a été aussi la difficulté sur
le consentement à la levée en masse pour
les pour les pour les guerres ce
consentement
vous ne pouvez pas l'obtenir
systématiquement quand les dirigeants
sont des dirigeants qui ne cesse de
faire des erreurs et qui font peser les
conséquences sur la population
c'est impossible vous aurez donc à la
fois la maladie
vous l'aurez donc à la fois la crise
économique vous aurez une crise sociale
vous aurez évidemment une crise des
institutions parce que vous ne pouvez
pas demander à des gens de mettre
l'orgie en parenthèse vous ne pouvez pas
demander à des gens de voir leurs
enfants commencé à avoir des problèmes
psychologiques vous ne pouvez pas
demander à des gens de ne pas voir leur
famille
deux de ne pas continuer à avoir leurs
amis vous ne pouvez pas demander à des
gens sur des périodes aussi longues
on parle de ça
ismène de demander à des gens d'arrêter
leur vie associative d'arrêter leur vie
spirituelle d'arrêter leur vie
philosophique
vous ne pouvez pas demander à des clubs
ou des gens qui se sont investis depuis
des années des clubs sportifs de mettre
la clé sous la porte
vous ne pouvez pas demander à des gens
de dabo lire leur vie voilà c'est là où
vous aurez un problème avec le
consentement
parce que vous ne pouvez pas demander
systématiquement à des gens de porter
les efforts quand vous avez été
incapable vous même dans d'apporter les
réponses du coup nous ne sommes pas au à
15 jours de ce qui s'est passé
nous sommes cette crise a commencé en
octobre novembre et nous en avons vu les
effets au mois de février mars
nous sommes nous sommes au moins nous
sommes au mois de novembre dans quelques
jours que s'est-il passé pendant tout ce
temps là du coup on fait quoi alexis
poulain parce que augmenter la capacité
des lits en réanimation
on le fait a dit le président la
république mais ce n'est pas la bonne
méthode
alors quelle solution finalement ça
c'est lui qui décrète que c'est pas la
bonne méthode comme à l'époque en mars
parce qu'on n'avait pas de masque il
décrétait que les masques étaient
inutiles il faut voir aussi le niveau
d'un curé qui fait qu' on adapte les
politiques parce que on n'a plus de
moyens ou parce qu'on fait en sorte de
ne pas avoir de moyens
le plan de relance très bien pour sauver
l'économie il va falloir le x 100 si on
veut vraiment sauver l'économie
il faudrait peut-être déjà avoir un plan
sanitaire tout simplement
à quoi sert françois bayrou avec ce
grand centre de planification qui ne
sert à rien encore une fois oui je suis
désolé les lis ça sert à quelque chose
n'en déplaise à monsieur macron c'est
juste que lui ne veut pas investir dans
l'hôpital il ne veut pas investir dans
le lit il ne veut pas mettre non plus
au travail enfin donc elle travaille
mais les cliniques privées dans un
dispositif qui serait un dispositif où
l'état deviendrait planificateur il
gérait cette crise sanitaire à la
hauteur de ce qu'on attend d'un état
planificateur il en est incapable
et c'est bien tout le problème quand
monsieur castex occupe de déconfinement
ce n'est pas lui qui s'occupe de
déconfinement il confie sa un cabinet de
conseil privé bennane compagnie qui fait
un travail lamentables puisque voilà où
nous en sommes après le déconfinement
c'est la déconfiture
et voilà qu'il nous dit maintenant ce
soir devant les caméras à d'un air
solennel qu'il va falloir re confiner le
pays parce qu'il n'y a pas d'autre
solution
il y en a tellement des solutions que ce
soit à la fois les lis que ce soit
planifié en amont et non pas réagir avec
toujours 15 jours de retard
quand on met en place le couvre-feu le
gouvernement sait très bien que c'est
une fausse mesure qui ne sert à rien à
part préparé les esprits à un recond
finement et bien pourquoi pas confiné
plus tôt ou alors dire eh bien puisque
c'est ça on lâche la faire et on va
faire autrement eh oui on va mettre le
paquet sur les soignants alors oui c'est
sûr il faut du temps pour former des
réanimateur anesthésiste des infirmiers
qui vont travailler dans ces services là
mais les italiens ont eu le temps de
recruter
et puis on peut former aussi des gens
qui sont déjà là à des protocoles
sanitaires de ranimation pour gérer
cette crise le temps de la crise on ne
demande pas d'avoir des réalisateurs à
foison pour les années qui viennent mais
au moins d'avoir des gestes qui sauvent
les bons réflexes et les soignants je
tiens à les saluer ce soir parce que
c'est eux qui tiennent finalement tout
sur leurs épaules c'est eux qui ont su
s'adapter qui ont mis des protocoles
sanitaires qui font qu'aujourd'hui on a
un tube plus comme on l'a fait en mars
et que finalement en réanimation c'est
beaucoup plus efficace c'est eux qui
demandent sans cesse plus de moyens qui
aujourd'hui se retrouve encore avec des
pénuries de matériel
c'est eux qui prennent tout dans la tête
et que que proposait macron insécure de
la santé pour vaguement revaloriser les
salaires loin de ce qui devrait être en
fait pour remettre les salaires des
infirmières françaises au niveau
européen et les moyens jamais parce que
la réponse d'emmanuel macron et c'était
il ya trois semaines devant les
soignants c'est un problème
d'organisation ce n'est pas un problème
de moyens donc tant qu'on aura cette
logique au pouvoir tant qu'on aura ces
gens là au pouvoir eh bien nous pourrons
pleurer des larmes de sang est resté
chez nous à regarder la télé et à
regarder un épisode
d'une mauvaise série d'une fin du monde
au lieu de vivre et là je crois que
franchement il va falloir que les
politiques répondent devant les
responsables de la nation que la
démocratie enfin reprenne ses droits
qu'on ait des commission denquête
sérieuse et que l'on fasse au delà des
chaînes de contamination les chaînes de
responsabilité qui font qu'on arrive
dans cette faillite totale de l'état
français arnaud cet effort on arrive au
terme de cet échange néanmoins en
quelques mots sur la question des
frontières elle a été beaucoup posé un
depuis le début de l'épidémie
nos frontières resteront ouvertes à
l'intérieur de l'europe
vous le comprenez ça non il aurait en
non par ce nom parce que vous ne
maîtrisez vous ne maîtrisez que ce que
vous contrôlez on peut pas demander jeu
il ya certainement de des gens très bien
qui sont qui sont très sourcilleux sur
quiron trou qui sort mais moi je suis
français je ne sais pas comment ça se
passe dans les autres pays
je suis incapable de dire si les choses
se font correctement
encore une fois depuis le début il avait
été il avait été dit qu'il aurait fallu
très vite fermer nos frontières
à tel point même que d'autres pays
européens l'ont fait devant nous et nous
avons continué à le nier l'allemagne je
me rappelle j'étais en direct ce soir là
l'allemagne venait de fermer c'est fermé
sa frontière et sur les plateaux on
expliquait que pas du tout c était juste
en train de faire des contrôles
renforcés
bon voilà encore une fois la france
continue à faire le phare de la le phare
de l'universel de l'universalisme prend
des décisions qui ne valent plus pour
elle et puis les autres lui impose ce
qui doit se passer c'est à dire la
sécurité
et des citoyens des autres pays voilà
les italiens est fermé il y avait des
images envoyait des italiens qui
rentrait en france et des français qui
ne pouvait pas rentrer en italie en
allemagne ça a été la même chose
je pense que sa paille ce n'est pas très
raisonnable encore une fois de ne pas
contrôler nos frontières un grand merci
à tous les deux d'avoir partager votre
point de vue après cette annonce du chef
de l'état 1 re confinement généralisée
donc merci a vous arnaud stéphan
communicants ex conseiller communication
presse de marion maréchal-le pen et
merci à vous alexis poulain
éditorialistes